jacob
sorry buddy you're not going
come
on miss you buddy
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well welcome to louisiana you excited to
be here jake
each of my boys have got to go on an
awesome father and son trip when tommy
was six me and becca took him to kyoto
japan when nathan was four he got to go
with me on a camping carp fishing trip
in spain well jacob's almost four so
it's his turn so i'm here in louisiana
and we
are going to be doing some awesome
hunting and fishing and adventures in
the bayou
hey everyone how are we doing we're
doing great so you ready to see some
alligators and stuff
yeah so we're here near morgan city
louisiana and i'm here with stafford
cavalier with cajun experience and this
is our third time
third trip with these guys if you guys
follow our channel you'll know we've had
some pretty amazing adventures with
these guys and this is one of our
favorite trips so we're gonna be
spending five days here we're gonna be
hunting frogs catching catfish
hunting ducks i mean
gar we're going to do it all it's going
to be awesome and as always guys if you
want to do this too i'm going to put
cajun experiences info down in the video
description so you guys can check them
out and do this as
well now jake you know what this is for
this is protect you from jumping fish
so a jumping fish comes it doesn't hit
you
oh it's beautiful
i remember we were driving out the first
day yeah
yeah see look it's a floating house it's
a houseboat
hi jacob come say hi to miss belinda
come on this is the guest bunk house
here got a whole bunch of bunk beds in
here
little kitchen shower bathroom
got a second bathroom some
bunk beds
nice and cozy hey jake you hungry buddy
you want some food you're gonna you're
gonna get a good old-school booster seat
yeah you're looking like a good what 20
quarts taller you like the deer meat
yeah it's good isn't it
we got homemade fresh gumbo here we got
some fried venison backstrap we got
catfish a potato salad white beans yeah
this is nice
jake you know what these are
these are the scale of a giant gar
they're even serrated yeah oh yeah they
aren't look at that that is wicked you
want to go out late at night and catch a
fish
body at all
[Music]
got a half a mullet here
threaded onto some serious steel cable
a big old hook on it
attached to a jug just chuck it out
there and try to get an alligator guard
to swallow that thing you want me to
throw it back
check that tomorrow
seven more put your hand in though
these are way better
better harder
we're gonna see some carp jump out of
the water
[Music]
whoa
he's pointing at an alligator alligator
right there
well that was fun but we really didn't
have much time to do anything other than
check a few jugs because uh we decided
we're going duck hunting tomorrow
morning and we got to get up at 5 00 a.m
so i'm gonna put the camera down
and get this crew to bed
[Music]
we're gonna go duck honey and i haven't
done it since i was a teenager i
love to eat ducks i love to catch ducks
good morning
[Music]
all right jake come on
we got a little fork to hide the boat
from the ducks
yeah we got a little blind man out of
willows here and we're in the middle of
the bayou and uh as soon as the sun
starts to peak up we're gonna get wood
ducks flying around and we're gonna see
how rusty i am yeah they got something
so stafford's doing the wood duck squeak
and now we got a little bit of light
coming over the horizon but i better
turn this light off
he's down
right there
humanitarian shooting i am so rusty i've
shot a shotgun movie twice in the last
15 years but this is so much fun
i don't want to talk about it my
shooting skills have turned this into a
bird watching trip with guns
man that was awesome it was just fast
action but it's uh the shooting's kind
of done for the day so we're gonna go
pick up our ducks
[Music]
oh there's one right there
he just landed right there
the best duck call is the sound of an
unloading gun look right here right here
jacob back up
look at that
beautiful
it's funny did you call it right to the
right
you did real good for early in the
morning
okay
you want to hold this
here come with me let's go over here
we'll take a picture
i was so surprised that i walked out and
seen him with that all right i got one
oh yeah
pull it apart
yeah your duck's naked look at that
pretty little bit of duck meat
there you go a little gizzard all right
gotcha
gotta sit on the pot
yeah
oh good one of the things i love about
cajun experience here is you can kind of
tailor each experience to whatever you
want to do we show up and staffers just
like
what do you want to do today jacob we
need to figure out what we want to do
today you want to hunt nutria maybe hunt
squirrels do you want to catch catfish
do you want to spear fish do you want to
catch crabs do you want to catch a frog
[Music]
you want a spear fish
and maybe maybe we go set some traps out
for nutria too all right guys it's
starting to warm up and get beautiful
we're going to go out and pull some fish
traps and check some nutria traps and
just kind of do the whole cajun
experience here you can tell because
they're when they walked it
miss blind has been cooking up some
wonderful fried catfish for us so we
need to stock up on some catfish we're
gonna pull a hoop net that uh stafford
set out we're gonna see how many catfish
we can catch you want to do it jake you
can do it you and your dad can do it you
hold this okay go for it throw it
[Music]
throw back the little guys
hey check it out guys this is where we
did our camping video last time
oh
me and the boys we we had to wade
through the bayou to get here
but it's all high and dry now
[Applause]
we've got our catfish on ice we're gonna
try doing a little buffalo fishing
little carp fishing we're gonna check
some traps i mean we're gonna do a whole
bunch of stuff it's going to be nice
we have this
big corn nice hair rig we're determined
to go catch some carp and buffalo
because that's what i love to do
so we're going to take some boiled corn
and some bait and we're gonna get uh get
some fish
look at that
right here on the floor
uh guys it's turning out to be a
gorgeous day it's like 70 degrees and
just we're gonna have a great time
yeah it looks like it's sprung but
don't get your finger in that's to hurt
so what we're doing is we're trying to
trap neutria nutria are an invasive
mammal from south america they look kind
of like a muskrat
and they're all over the place and they
tear up the vegetation and the
embankment and cause a lot of problems
so the government has put out a bounty
on them and they're also have very
beautiful fur and tasty meat so we're
gonna try to catch some and get the fur
and eat the meat and collect the bounty
but you can see what we do here is we
have this little trail that comes here
this is a nutria trail and it comes
through
here
and so
they like to rub up against these
cypress knees so we got a little trap
right there
we shot a thousand with the customers in
march that was four thousand we pulled
it up last year
oh i see him see him right there
that's a lot bigger than a musketeer
yeah she got some teeth yeah those will
chew a hole
here oh man down
here just rub it on his boat as much as
possible yeah yeah go
so apparently new tree can reproduce
like crazy they can have babies after
three months and then it only takes them
about three months
to have their babies once they get
pregnant and then they can get pregnant
again the day they give birth to their
babies and they can have 13 babies in
one litter
it's crazy
you caught it crawfish you wanna you
wanna pick him up no he said don't toss
him
you pinch him right here
and they can't get you
you wanna try
thank you yeah look at that he was just
crawling on the banks
[Music]
we're driving by we see some of our gar
fishing jugs so we gotta go check those
out see if we have any alligator gar on
these things are huge big old dinosaur
fish they get over 200 pounds
it's going to smell really really good
imagination
look we have one though look it's just
made
they get bigger than that
part of the jaw
how do we even
yeah it's really easy now just see the
fish oh he's going he's pulling it under
the boat
there you go
and grab it grab it right here
bigger than the last one we call it
[Music]
oh that is a nice fish look at that
45 yeah
look at the size of that isn't that a
massive fish
but listen if you don't calm down back
there i'm turning this boat around guys
get along back there we just wrestled a
40-pound alligator gar over jacob's head
and he didn't even wake up
[Music]
all right guys we're in a hot little
spot we saw tons of buffalo here last
night so we're going to try to target
them on rod and reel and uh just kind of
see what happens got a big thing of
boiled feed corn here
we got our panko jello sweet corn mix
here two of these kernels of corn on the
end of the hook this big ball of bait
here we're gonna stick it onto this
method lid
stick it on the top just like that we've
got three rods out we've got three
different spots chummed up we're gonna
see what happens well we've been sitting
here for about an hour gave it a little
go with the buffalo no bites but uh
we're gonna keep trying on this we're
gonna keep trying on this but
i want to go spearfishing tonight so
we're gonna pull it up go try that jacob
we need to wake you up buddy
you want to go spearfish
look at those teeth
those scales just like armor
right there
that is a pile of meat right there
oh yeah this
this right here is the biggest smoker
i've ever seen
and uh tomorrow they're gonna fill that
full of garment
i love smoked fish well my reputation as
a carp fisherman is on the line here and
so i am determined to catch a buffalo or
a carp
so i'm going to rig up the carp rig and
the same bait we were using earlier i'm
going to just chum a whole bunch of it
off at the dock here
and that way we can fish well we go get
some dinner
we'll see if we catch anything all right
jake you ready for dinner
oh look at this we've got gar stew
potatoes and uh rice potato salad this
is good solid food here
yeah it's really good
all right bud let's get you all dressed
up and warm
it's night time and we are going to go
spear some fish and check out this sweet
new setup stafford's got for spear and
fish this thing's awesome
look at this jake
yeah we'll be able to see some fish with
this you have upgraded a lot
seriously
all right you ready though i'm ready
that's not bad
oh
there you go
i got it
there we go
oh you hear that sound
nice guard right through that
look at that
[Music]
right here did you see my light oh you
scared him
look at that guy's got a bowfin that's a
delicious fish
i've had a couple times i was worried
about the string breaking
look at that sucker
yeah yeah
there we go
yeah nice buffalo so that is the buffalo
yeah look at the black on black eyes
you got how'd you get all that fish
slime on your console really i used to
have better clients than this
there we go got another buffalo
oh yes that surprise fish
oh yeah there we go
oh
that was a big buffalo
look at that
oh i think you missed it
we got a scale
i got him
you got him yeah i got him
look at that
so you're gonna eat that one right oh
yeah what type is that that's that looks
like a big head carved to me
but i wanted to get one of these so bad
oh that is a beast i'll put his thing
away he's supporting yeah he feels like
he's about 20. yeah he's a big fish look
at that now
you finally got your fist hey oh
that is awesome look at that
he is huge
oh we're eating asian carp
we got up at 5 a.m and it's now midnight
i think it's time to call it but oh what
a night we have caught so many fish we
are set up with uh crawfish and crab
bait for a while here we got all his
buffalo in here
you got some bowfin and
some mold or two
little jacob just woke up too
he's been zonked out but i think it's
time to get him to bed ah you've been
such a good boy jacob
got him to bed i'll see you guys in the
morning
i'm a little tired how about you
go buddy look at this wonderful
breakfast i gotta tell you i love
biscuits and gravy i could eat that just
about every day i'm
[Music]
well today harvey's gonna fire up the
smoker and smoke a ton of that gar meat
i swear that is the biggest smoker i've
ever seen
we're gonna do to those shark pieces
we got back after midnight last night
from spearing fish so we just threw
everything on ice and i think it's time
we needed to flay up that big head asian
carp and uh we're gonna try to cook them
up today
check it out this is an asian carp here
this is an invasive fish from china they
were introduced in the united states for
wastewater treatment purposes and they
escaped during a big flood on the
mississippi and they're just all over
the mississippi basin now and there's
two species there's the big head carp
and the silver carp but they're filter
feeders kind of like gizzard shad or
paddlefish they swim around and suck up
zooplankton and their meat is a lot like
crappie meat but if they've got a lot of
bones in them and i think uh miss
belinda is a little dubious about eating
one of these yeah yeah
in eastern russia china and brazil these
are a popular fish to fish for on rod
and reel and a lot of people love to eat
these
the meat on these asian carp is gorgeous
it's just a nice white meat you get a
little bit of the red stuff up against
the skin the biggest problem is there's
bones in it
[Applause]
so there'll be one bone in between each
one that's prime carb rib right
yeah the buffalo won't be the same this
is exactly how we're doing buffalo so if
we had a buffalo with ribs this may be
delicious it might get off surprises too
i wouldn't this is another one of these
cookies
works well
oh yeah we do some buffalo ribs on the
bigger ones and the rest will be used
for crab pots and uh hopefully we'll get
some crabs today
gonna make some gar hooks here we go
yeah stainless steel
feed it in the hook
[Applause]
there we go
on there gotcha hopefully
we got garmeet in the smoker we got
guard jugs ready to go we've got some
seasoned carp meat in the fridge we're
gonna go wake jacob up and uh we're
gonna go pull some crab traps and uh
throw some jug lines out it's gonna be a
good day
wake up bud
wakey wakey
wake up
two hours later where is he
oh that real tank look
yes sir drop it
good job throw it hard throw it hard
yeah
drop it slowly
there you go
go through it
okay
when i tell you you throw it hard when i
tell you three throw it
[Music]
this is why i love coming back here to
cajun experience there's all this fun
things that the kids can do it's a great
way to have an outdoor experience even
if they're real little are you ready
jacob
we're on the tail end of the blue crab
seasons blue crab here are enormous
and delicious so we're going to try to
see if we can't get a couple
grab it right there look right there
grab the rope and pull
yeah well that's rope's not so bad
you don't like if we're going to stop
bleeding when i'll come back get them
tomorrow or something
throw it
hello freshwater drum what do you call
them caspar cass bagoon that's on a rock
yeah yeah
little louisiana blue crab look at the
size of this thing this is kind of like
a small average isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
now we're gonna look at the size of
these blue crabs these things are
enormous that's nothing to brag about
but that's not bad for december yeah
we're gonna eat blue crabs tonight if
there's one thing stafford likes to eat
with his asian carp it's blue crab
see a big alligator oh there's another
one right there look at all the claw
marks from the alligators pulling
themselves up on the log that's cool
was that cool to see those alligators
yeah i like it all right we're gonna do
one of my favorite things here we're
gonna throw the cast at see if we can't
catch some more bait stafford here uses
a lot of mullet we're we're gonna try a
big net today
it was too late
i gots you gotta guard that godzilla
day nice little buffalo
so that's a different one huh there we
go another buffalo week
we got a mess
all right there we go
trying to get him in the water
and look what i did to stafford's boat
and the front of his boat is disgusting
come on
looks like some of the smoked gar is
done so we're going to test that out
look at that smoked car that is a bucket
of guard
oh good good oh good
that's a little bit that is really good
oh my god all right the infamous asian
carp here we've got some creole
seasoning mustard uh am i missing
something egg egg
friar here
we're frying car people
look at this we're gonna we're gonna try
some asian car beer
no there are catfish or anything else to
move
[Laughter]
i think it tastes fine tastes like every
other white meat fresh water fish i've
ever eaten but well i'm digging the
fried carp though i uh might be alone in
that
all right i'm gonna try some carp rib
here
try some asian carp man
yeah it's not the best it's edible yeah
now you try the buffalo ribs man you
don't need ketchup for that that's
absolutely a different kind of meat
difference good
no it's absolutely this is the buffalo
ribs watch the hot i'll tell you i give
it a fair shake
yeah you gave it a version now you can
hold it hold it like this oh those are
big boys
all right suck hello
in these pieces you have some more meat
in here too good meat it's good crab
meat yeah yeah
daddy did he like human meat it tastes
like human meat did he say human meat
what are you teaching this kid
all right guys we're out here looking
for frogs and we've got these
high-powered headlamps and we're shining
them along the weed beds looking for
glowing frog eyes shine the light in
their eyes so they don't move then try
to grab and uh hopefully we can catch a
couple and cook up some frog legs see
look at the grass right here like that
right there see that right there the
green frog see ya
oh there's another frog jake another
frog
grab my heart
oh you got him oh you got him jake he
can't fit in the cage so why don't you
let him go
there he goes
give me a high five that was a great
frog catcher do you do a frog dance
oh i can see his eye now
you got him
oh jacob that yeah you got him that was
100
by himself no he just goes i got him
look at you you're you're the best frog
catcher i've ever seen bud
there we go way to go five
all right oh look at the size of that
spider on that tree trunk that is the
biggest spider i've ever seen
look at the size of that spider
and he's right there's one right there
jake just spotted a frog all by himself
oh i see him
here jake get him get him you're not
playing you like grab both his legs you
got him oh he just beat on you yeah he's
he's a big boy
got it oh he is big
sorry guys
you've got snacks that is a big boy
how do you make that look at you nice
kiss i think jacob's going down right
there i think i see an eye right there
[Music]
there we go
our jake's gone
[Music]
dead head
get rid of my coat i grabbed him but he
you did like a magician's trick
oh and he came up where did the frog
come from magic
but uh i think
we've got enough for a frog dinner there
well we've been pretty good frog hunting
even though it's only been a couple
hours but it's nine o'clock and we gotta
get to bed because we're getting up
early tomorrow morning so uh we better
head back
well good morning guys it's five in the
morning and we're doing a little more
duck hunting you ready for me to waste
more of your ammo i'm ready
all right guys we're just hanging out
here in a little cypress wood duck blind
waiting for the sun to come up we're
gonna see if i can't hit any ducks today
[Music]
good girl on
come on
okay sit hey
fetch him up
i forgot how much i love duck hunting
you just sit here and you're blind
watching those ducks come in and cup in
their wings you pop up all heck breaks
loose
so
got him
well that's three now
all right dixie you want to go find some
ducks with me got it there you go when
luke got in the blind i gave him three
of these right full to the top
this one right here
yeah it's gone stafford how many did you
lose really luke come on you're gonna do
a lot of work to pay for those sales i
say all right let's start off over this
way
oh my goodness good girl there we go
guys three wood ducks
we found them
look at that i think it's been a good
day live it out
yeah i'm gonna just leave you here i'm
not anyone
why mmm i missed you jake jacob did you
catch a frog last night
yeah he really did yeah all by himself
that tastes good jake
well it's been a good morning we got
lots of ducks and lots of frogs and lots
of good food to eat today so stafford
and harvey will be cleaning up ducks and
i'm gonna try to clean up some frogs
that right there are the frog legs
that is delicious meat right there oh
all the things we eat here at cajun
experience this is probably my favorite
got lunch all cleaned up
look at this jake's out cold
i'm gonna sit down and eat some lunch
while he sleeps we got
frog legs
rice stuffing
boone balls
and gar balls there you go these are
booting balls i did it wrong didn't i
i've never pronounced these correctly
the savory meat and rice ball that's
deep fried it's nice
well jake woke up you're going to try
some frog legs now oh and a booty ball
nope
that's a frog leg
ribbit check this fish are you ready
well for dinner we're gonna be eating
those ducks so uh harvey's got the
propane torch out here and he's showing
us how it's done
oh it smells so good in here
oh my wow i'm getting excited about
those ducks
i think it's time to go on the boat
[Music]
all right we're gonna go uh set some
traps and check some traps
all right first nutria trap is shut and
nobody's home
now that's how you do it luke that is a
big animal hey
look at that thing came on outside of
the boat
[Music]
i still got all my fingers
let me get some character
oh yeah
here we go
for years the nutria population was kept
in check by commercial fur harvesting
but because fur isn't that popular
anymore people don't do it and so the
nutria population exploded so now they
have to offer a bounty to get people to
kill them to keep their populations in
check
i'm liking it lucas yeah let's do it
right here yeah like right there
watch your fingers okay he's almost
professional at this now
four four in one day
hold on check this out jake
look what's over here
it's something very that's that seems
fresh i mean it's not it's not super
crunchy
snake's good
we got a lot of debris in the back of
the boat and things like this so
stafford's solution is to to put an
enormous hole in the boat i'm gonna just
take all my valuables off the floor
there we go
go flush in the boat
yeah that's
i've had this rod on the dock for three
days i keep throwing feed corn and panko
and jello off the side trying to see to
catch a buffalo haven't gotten a bite
not a catfish not nothing and we know
there's buffalo down there we caught
some of the cast net earlier so
uh
yeah i'm really thinking that the
buffalo around here don't care about
corn i've gotta i've gotta do some
thinking and come up with some different
baits for next time we come back
oh my goodness look at that those ducks
are looking good
smells amazing in here does that look
good yeah
oh wow
nobody was scared yeah wait let's try
some time
okay
these little wood ducks are tasty mine
is way better
all right jake should we go spear a fish
yeah right now all right all right
yeah
my big goal coming here was to spear a
big head asian carp and we did it we ate
it it was awesome tonight i want jacob
to spear a fish pick up are you ready
you see that alligator
feel that is that cool jake
that's still a good height though that's
awesome
oh that was a great thrill
a lot of times i wanted you to try out
daddy's spear
wait wait yeah he just lets that go he's
gonna stab something
i'm ready bro
got him i think i think you got him
i think you got him jake yeah put him in
the ball put him straight up look
straight up straight up straight up
what way to go
you did it you speared a catfish
too yeah he was born ready i guess he
was watching you were born
oh right ready oh my glasses
oh i am never finding those all right i
was trying to throw the spear at
something and i hit my glasses and
knocked them into the bayou here i'm not
holding out a lot of hope well he didn't
find my glasses but look at the size of
that clam
well the glasses are gone but i'm not
sad what a wonderful night was that fun
spearing that catfish
i'm happy that you caught that catfish
well it's probably bedtime huh let's get
you to bed
i am going to put this down and see you
guys in the morning
well good morning guys it's our last day
here at cajun experience and i'm just
packing up and cleaning up while jacob
sleeps in and i'm i'm going through this
guest book and i can see where me and
tommy signed it way back in 2018 this is
our third trip to cajun experience i've
been filming guided fishing trips and
family-friendly outdoor adventures for
seven years and people ask me what my
number one recommendation is in the
united states it's cajun experience i'll
put their website and their information
down the link below definitely check
them out i better finish packing and get
jacob up because we have a little bit
more fun planned for today
this video isn't over yet
oh my goodness those are beignets
i could actually pronounce though that
came out perfect
here take try it dry cajun donut
i had a good harvey has been a pleasure
you too hey
[Music]
do you think we should come back with
mommy
yeah
[Music]
that's a little bit pricey
stafford it was a pleasure oh every time
it's just awesome it's just uh we got to
bring becca back bring becca oh i don't
believe becca exists but bring abby
bring the actress that plays back on the
youtube videos
[Music]
[Music]
further down
guys i hope you enjoyed watching this
video as much as we enjoyed filming it
if you want to see more travel and
adventure videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to check
our travel adventure playlist and don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every saturday morning
sky
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]